so nobody asked for this but what the
heck this trailers for us before you go
into the spider-verse
enter an even weirder alternate
dimension 1970s Japan Japanese
spider-man born from a short-lived
licensing deal between Marvel Comics and
to--a
comes a loose adaptation of the
webslinger like very loose we're instead
of the same old whiny high school with a
spider bite you'll follow a motocross
racer with the enchanted blood of a
dying alien from Planet spider alright
who gives him a flying car that docks
into a giant robot okay and sends him on
a mission of lethal revenge while I
shall commit no honey it's like American
spider-man if Uncle Ben's dying wish for
Peter was to become the Punisher you
know it's an always couple
[Music]
okay it's actually nothing like American
spider-man experienced a show that's
virtually identical to Power Rangers
where every episode has our hero
transforming after yelling into a
handheld device spider popping pop then
fighting some putties until a cloaked
villain makes a monster grow only to get
beat down by a Voltron but since
Japanese spider-man actually came out
first now you can say the Megazord is
actually just a cheap ripoff of leo part
on it will make any friends but still
you know you could say it tired of CGI
special effects return to a time when
all they had to work with was a rope in
a dream where the monster of the week
was made out of fur suits in garbage
wall-crawling was more of a steady
wiggled basic gymnastics were looped to
make them more impressive and the same
net footage had to keep getting reused
because someone stole the suit halfway
through production
[Music]
oh man that sucks shoulda put you
happening spider-man on the case so if
you're suffering from superhero fatigue
and joy a fresh take on the character
that may not be the strongest version or
the most brave or the smartest guy you
kinda narcotic spider on the whole
knuckle mutant Optima but before you
feel too superior it's still more fun
than the show Marvel was crapping out
stateside man this could really use a
killer robot starring takuya's mm face
Naruto running tiny shorts dramatic
faces
dramatic zoos
[Music]
dramatic death
dummies such the human
[Music]
slaps child abuse
[Applause]
[Music]
murderer
suicide this show gets dark poorly
translated episode days Yannick Apache
ie no got preamble poorly translated
monster names
[Music]
spider-man workshopping his catchphrase
well do I you know go to home spy Tom
you know who are noble final say those
who don't you because of slow to go spy
Dava and spider-man settling on his
catchphrase Okaloosa spider do you color
Mosher spied on yokonomo show spy dharma
just once I want to hear Tobey Maguire
yo that we love spider-man spider-man wa
kono mama so-nanoka- Monique Torito no
Maya Cara Theotokos Tucker discussion
sorry buddy due for a night
Jonah Mamata wanna do my idea done what
why are you buying clothes at the soup
store we are Groot and venno part of the
journey is the end underground
overground wombling free the Wombles of
women that common are we I am secretly a
Brody